good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight joe biden wants you to
know that he has suddenly a year and a
half
in developed a mild curiosity about
where this pandemic
came from it turns out the virus
probably didn't originate in omaha more
than that joe biden can't say
but he's put some of his top slews on it
the super spies in the so-called
intel community and they have promised
to report back at some point
as of today two-thirds of joe biden's
spies believe
the virus jumped naturally to human
beings from an infected animal
as viruses so often do as you peruse the
pangolin isle in your local wet market
the spies who believe that are the ones
who have never spoken to a working
virologist and don't have
internet access but the other third joe
biden told us today quote
lean more toward the theory that kovit
escaped from a nearby government lab in
wuhan that happened to be conducting
dangerous experiments on nearly
identical bat coronaviruses
at the same time that's a minority of
spies who believe that but they're open
to the possibility who knows really
either way joe biden explained we're
going to get some answers or at least
more questions
possibly several months from now so rest
assured the white house is on it
and to be honest we doubted that just
hours before joe biden's announcement we
learned that the white house had shut
down a large
ongoing and legitimate federal
investigation into the origins of this
pandemic
that investigation had been going on for
months it was being conducted by the
state department's bureau of
arms control verification and compliance
that's the bureau responsible for
ensuring
that countries like china are not
stockpiling deadly illegal bioweapons
such as for example obscure back
coronaviruses that have been manipulated
in labs by military scientists to make
them more transmissible and say
new york city so why did the white house
shut down that ongoing investigation
well at a hearing today senior officials
at the national institutes of health
that would include
dr tony fauci said they had no idea why
the white house shut it down they said
they first heard about it on the news
and that seemed odd given that the nih
does employ the nation's foremost
experts on infectious diseases and of
course
they're closely linked to the story it
was nih was your tax dollars actually
but funneled through nih
that funded some of the grotesque and
dangerous research of the now infamous
wuhan institute of technology that may
have caused the destruction
of the west so today senator john
kennedy of louisiana
asked all of these questions here's how
it went
why did you guys spike not guys and
ladies
why did y'all spike the prior
administration's
uh investigation into the origins of the
coronavirus and whether it could have
uh come out of the muhan lab
sir i i we did not spike anything in the
prior administration i'm not sure what
you mean by spike
but we have no influence the state
department spiked the
the prior administration's uh study but
that has nothing to do with the national
institutes of health they didn't consult
with y'all
they did not did they consult with you
dr collins i read about it in the press
this morning
doc they just spiked it without talking
to their experts
you don't want to answer that one do you
they definitely didn't want to answer so
we still don't know why the white house
ended a months-long investigation into
the central question of the moment
we also don't know what that
investigation found before it was
closed we do have some ideas about that
though
a fact sheet released by the state
department in the closing days of the
last
administration written by some of the
same people who are doing the
investigation of the bidet
administration shut down
told us that several researchers at the
wuhan institute of virology became
seriously ill in the fall of 2019 they
had quote
symptoms consistent with both covet 19
and common seasonal
illness three of them went to the
hospital now that came out in january
the american media caught up this week
the intel community confirmed it
in a statement to fox news today the
state department contractor that led
that now defunct probe a man called
david asher reiterated that
based on that investigation's findings
so far
quote there is probable cause for deep
suspicion
that the virus escaped from the lab in
wuhan and the chinese government
lied about it so why don't we know more
well according to that same david asher
powerful forces in the state department
did not
want to know more they didn't want to
continue asking questions
they didn't like the investigation whose
side are they on
you wonder and david asher clearly is
wondering the same thing quote
some of our colleagues were deliberately
playing down possible links to china's
biological weapons program
end quote now why would they be doing
that again
whose side are they on this was all very
troubling to david asher
who spent a lot of time looking into
this given that countries like china
quote openly aim to incorporate
synthetic biology
into the future of warfare apparently
with our naive material and scientific
assistance end quote now that's a
reference of course that the
to the money that flowed from the u.s
government through nih
to the wuhan lab to do research that may
have been
connected to this pandemic david asher
named a man called chris ford
that's the former acting under secretary
for arms control the state department
as someone who quote didn't want to
delve into the potential of an
accidental lab release
let alone one related to a possible
classified chinese military program
in violation of arms conventions now
why would an official in the u.s
government not want to know
more about an adversary a foreign
adversary
violating international law and
imperiling
the lives of millions that's a great
question
now ford himself responded to fox news
and he said he had quote
procedural and structural concerns about
the probe
including that he was kept out of the
loop until december
but he emphasized quote the lab origin
theory is very possible and china must
be held to account
there are all sorts of reasons to worry
about possible lab origins
and it's critical to get to the bottom
of it so that's chris ford's position
now we hope it always has been it should
be the position
of everyone in the u.s government
suddenly it's a position of the u.s
media
virtually every news organization in the
country has spent the last week
frantically updating its lies about this
story
they've told you for more than a year it
was a conspiracy theory now they're
pretending they never said that
even tony faucis had to revise his views
on this he dismissed it out of hand
he and francis collins at the nih who
called it outrageous
to ask questions about it now a new tony
fauci
just a few hours ago fauci admitted that
he really has no idea what kind of
research was going on
at the wuhan institute of virology but
we probably should look into it
how do you know they didn't lie to you
and use the money for gain of function
research anyway
well we've seen the results of the
experiments that were done
and that were published and that the
viruses that they
um uh studied are on
public databases now so none of that was
gain of functions so
how do you know they didn't do the
research and
not put it on their website there's no
way of
guaranteeing that so found you with a
straight face just said
we can be certain that no us tax dollars
went to gain of function experiments
because the chinese didn't write about
it on the internet
that's how we know with a straight face
and when pressed just a little bit
by one of the very few senators who's
not brain dead
facts she admitted actually no he has no
idea really what u.s tax dollars
went to which experiments they funded at
the wu hun institute of virology
either way this is a total revision of
anthony fauci's position on the subject
it was just a few days ago
that he was incensed he was outraged
morally appalled by the suggestion
that he had funded gain of function
experiments in china
now he's conceding yeah it's totally
possible
but of course he has always known that
it was totally possible
the grant that tony fauci approved for
research at the wuhan lab
explicitly permits gain of function
experiments
in 2014 tony fauci's niaid approved
a grant for a project called
understanding the risk of bat
coronavirus emergence
that project would be run by a group
called eco health alliance
overseen by a man called peter dazek if
that name sounds familiar
that's the same peter daza who spent the
last year telling the world at high
volume
there's no chance this virus escaped
from the web and then
was appointed by the world health
organization to investigate the origins
of kovid
and declared the wuhan lab blameless
what a scam but the grant from fatchi's
nia niaid states that it will fund peter
dasak to quote
test predictions of coronavirus
interspecies transmission predictive
models of host range
i.e emergence potential and will be
tested experimentally using reverse
genetics
pseudovirus and receptor binding assays
and virus infection experiments across a
range of cell
cultures from different species and
humanized mice
oh so actually that's quite a
broad range run that by any scientist
and they will tell you
a lot fits under that description but
specifically
what did those virus infection
experiments with back corona viruses
consist of
precisely well we don't know we have
some idea
seems like maybe the results are all
around us the white house wants you
to calm down they want you know the
intelligence community and no one else
will have to answer
these questions at some point in the
next few months
and if you can't trust them who can you
trust you don't need a real
investigation
you can take their word for it hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else